morning everyone welcome to the
conference welcome to this talk my name
is Michael Simon and I am a functional
programmer today I want to talk about
how in general in the software industry
we choose our languages our libraries
and frameworks what I'm gonna be saying
applies to all three of those mostly
what you're gonna hear me say is gonna
be focused on languages just to avoid
saying those three things over and over
again the main question is how can we do
it better than we do it today and I'm
gonna start this talk off by talking
about mic history of how I've chosen
languages and how I eventually got to
where I am today I've been programming
for about 25 years and I've been doing
Haskell for the past 10 years so how did
I get there the first two languages that
I learnt I learnt in grade school there
was someone who came into our class and
gave us a lesson on logo writer has
anyone here ever heard of logo writer so
it's a little bit of a stretch to call
that a programming language but we'll
call that my first language
I heard him relentlessly throughout the
course on how to do other things and he
kept only meat now you can't do that he
can't do that
and eventually he relented and he gave
me a book on cue basic or quick basic
towards the end of that course and I had
a dos computer at home so I was able to
use it and that was it it's fair to say
that that changed my life and I became a
programmer after that but you may notice
choosing those first two languages was
very very easy because I had absolutely
no choice
this is exactly what was delivered to me
I had no access to other kind of
information someone told me this is what
you're gonna do and that's what I did
later on at the local book store I was
able to find on sale some book on visual
C++ was probably some old edition of it
I didn't even have a visual C++ compiler
but I somehow made it work and I'm gonna
sleep less Plus and I did that for a
year and then Java became really popular
Java was gonna take over the world
everything on the front end was gonna be
done in Java the web browser is gonna be
dominated by Java applets you all
remember that right yeah and of course
that was obviously going to be the case
today we're doing
everywhere on the front end so I learnt
that because that was what the world
told me I needed to learn and then I did
Java for quite a few more years the
language selection process were all four
of those is pretty obvious there was not
much of one at all I did not have access
to a lot of learning material I had very
limited access to Tully I followed
whatever the obvious choice at the time
was whether it's because someone gave me
the book or the world had decided that
this is the programming language that I
should be mining all of that said I mean
it sounds like I'm saying this as a
terrible idea but actually that was
pretty decent criteria at the time given
the constraints that I had however
something happened we got the internet
we got access to a lot more information
and a lot more material became available
online but it came easy to get learning
material to get compilers to download
ideas all of this stuff was suddenly
available if I had enough time to wait
for my 56k or 28k whatever it was modem
to download the Java SDK or Python or
whatever it was that I was going to be
trying out now I could do it and
suddenly we were in the paradox of
choice is everyone familiar with the
paradox of choice oh you guys heard this
term basically the fact that I had all
of these choices available to me made
the situation more difficult not easier
there's still some defaults that remain
even in a world where we have access to
thousand programming languages available
to choose from if you're on a specific
platform you may be pushed in a certain
direction so if you're doing iOS
development you could do it in Haskell
you could do it in rust you could do it
in a bunch of languages but odds are if
you're just starting off you're gonna
end up doing objective-c or Swift these
days if you're doing Android you're
probably going to use Kotlin because
that's what's recommended a few years
ago that would have been Java 4 that's
fine things change over time if you're
working on an existing code base if you
have been thrown at a project that is a
two hundred thousand line C codebase
you're probably not going to rewrite it
in Haskell overnight you're probably
going to write that in C and when you
get thrown into some soul-sucking
corporate job that has a corporate
coding standard
you're gonna follow the standard because
you want to keep your job so there's
still some cases where you have a very
easy choice the paradox of choice
disappears what do you do if none of
that applies what if you're in one of
these programming domains where you
could use legitimately
20 30 or a hundred different languages
how do you choose which one of these
you're going to work with well here's a
non-starter approach fully evaluate
every single one of these languages
you've got a project I know I'm gonna
take all 100 languages that are
available and I am going to implement
the full project in that language and
every single one of those languages this
obviously is not going to work it takes
too much time it costs too much and I
don't just mean the cost to the business
or to yourself
I mean your mental health you are going
to go crazy trying to do this
theoretically there's some kind of a
deadline that you have to meet so I
don't think that's gonna happen
and at the rate that languages come out
this is actually a never-ending task you
will never be done testing every single
language that you could be using this by
the way is Sisyphus so is constantly
pushing the boulder up the hill we will
be doing the same thing with our
programming languages so obviously we
need some help and what I'm going to
describe now is the process more or less
that I think most of us use today to
determine which language we're going to
be using when we start a new project we
use some kind of evaluation tool these
things are gonna help us make that
should make that choice which up until
now seemed a very difficult since we've
already eliminated all of the easy ways
of doing things and what we want to be
able to do is we want to be able to
prune that set of languages we want some
kind of a system where we're going to
take that hundred languages 200
languages whatever it is and we're gonna
get it down to a manageable list and
manageable is probably very short it's
probably in the range of about five
languages and then we want to be able to
sort that in some kind of a priority
queue and then start going through these
things the first tool that I think a lot
of us use is benchmarks because we
programmers love benchmarks I've seen
this personally if I write a blog post
and I spend weeks working on this blog
post I talk about how awesome it is
is to work in a certain language or I
talk about some features or I teach a
very deep technical topic okay
if I throw together a benchmark in five
minutes and I claim that something I
wrote is 73% faster than the competition
everyone will get excited that's just
the way we are unfortunately benchmarks
can be misguided we think that they are
going to apply to what we're doing
usually we're not testing the same thing
that we're doing we're usually testing
something which is not the bottleneck in
our program
one of the common examples is HTTP vent
benchmarks and I've worked in that
usually in most web applications HTTP
processing is not the bottleneck of your
application so as excited as we get when
we see that one one web server is 90%
faster than the competition you're gonna
be lucky if you get a five percent
performance difference from that in
practice do not take this as me saying
that no one needs to worry about
performance that is the opposite of what
I believe however relying on benchmarks
isn't the best thing to do thing about
benchmarks though is that they are
objectives or at least seemingly
objective and everything else we're
going to talk about is not objective
most things that we end up talking about
when deciding on a language are
subjective criteria and this is why I
think benchmarks always come up as one
of the first things people look at when
deciding which language they want to use
you get a graph you get numbers numbers
can't lie it's impossible we all know
that numbers are absolute truth in all
cases and we like that but benchmarks
are deeply flawed all of that said they
are still valid and they should be part
of this evaluation metric if you have
some kind of performance criteria that
you must need in your application
looking at a benchmarking scene whether
something has any chance of meeting it
or not is valid my only point here is I
think we wait the benchmarks a little
bit too heavily in this process and we
consider them objective truth even
though we know that they can be
misleading because as we know people in
our industry have gone ahead and created
misleading benchmarks and they may not
be as relevant as we expect all right so
that's tool number one
- number two tool number two is height
we love to follow what everyone else is
doing if something is popular it has to
be good right no one has ever created a
programming language which was massively
popular but wasn't actually that good in
practice everyone is using it it's got
to be a good thing we know that this is
deeply flawed we know that this is not a
good way of evaluating something but it
does provide some signal if a whole
bunch of companies or a whole bunch of
individuals are working with some kind
of a language it has to be at least
somewhat decent so I'm not saying you
get no information from hype you get
some let's change that term and not talk
about hype let's talk about reputation
reputation doesn't sound quite as loaded
and we'll get into why hype is such a
loaded term in a second reputation that
a language has may be accurate or it may
be inaccurate therefore you need to know
whom to trust when you go through this
stage of the process odds are you're not
going out to random strangers you're
probably going to your friends your
co-workers your colleagues people you
trust and asking them for their opinions
of these different languages you can
also observe market trends on the
assumption that if dollars are going
somewhere if money is being spent in a
certain direction that's also some kind
of an indication even if it's not the
best of course the best way to choose a
language is to just trust reddit all
right so why is it that we hate hype so
much it's because of marketing in our
ideal world how much hype a language has
would be directly correlated to how good
the language actually is we know that's
not true
we know that it's possible to game the
system it's possible to make a language
look better than it actually is by
marketing it and that's why we have this
visceral negative reaction to hype and
know that we can't really rely on it so
the solution of this comes down to
something in economics game theory and I
say you have to hate the game not the
player don't get upset when someone goes
out there and markets their language or
markets whatever it is that they're
doing that's the only way to level the
playing field of someone in the world if
someone in the marketplace is going to
be doing the marketing ever and us to do
the marketing otherwise it's unfair
competition we'll get into this a little
bit more later one of the things that I
think we are
need to do in the functional programming
community is to a little bit of this
kind of marketing but we have to do it
correctly
we can't go out there and make false
claims crazy claims we have to be
accurate and we have to be respectful in
what we do ok so I've gone over this
process where are we now we know that we
have no default or obvious choice to
make in this between a programming
language we've eliminated a few
languages that are too slow to use we've
let reputation eliminate some others
we've come up with a list and now we
have a short list of five languages that
could reasonably solve our problem
whatever that happens to be has decent
enough performance numbers and there's
some subset of the world that you trust
that likes this language finally it's
time for step three on-ramp and this is
the hard part
this is the point where you take these
languages and you try to actually use
them this is hard this requires getting
used to these languages you have to
download tools you have to figure out
tools you have to go through tutorials
we have to implement hello world you're
going to implement some kind of other
example you're gonna start playing
around with this you're gonna get
halfway through the first language and
you're gonna get fed up and you're gonna
move on to the second language you're
gonna get really upset that this
language has curly braces or maybe that
it doesn't have curly braces whatever
the case is you're gonna hate something
about the language and you're gonna
complain about it this is a hard process
and it takes some real time but after
going through one two maybe three of
these languages maybe you'll go through
all five eventually you're gonna figure
out and one of these languages is the
right language this is obviously the
best and you are going to go ahead and
implement your project in it and now
language X is your language you are a
language X developer you identify that
way and I think this is a process that
most people in this room have probably
gone through to some extent in the past
especially if you're at a functional
programming conference you've probably
done that soul-searching looking for
what the next language is going to be
there are problems with this approach
the process I described can easily take
one to two months to make a decision
that is a non-trivial amount of time and
a significant amount of work from a
business perspective it's still costly
and I'm going to claim that all of that
is unavoidable as much as we would like
to
jumpstart that process we can't even if
I go to someone and say Haskell's good
go use it they're not gonna just listen
to me and they shouldn't they should do
this analysis themselves and figure out
what to do so I'm gonna call these
fundamental inherent problems that must
exist but there are two more other
fundamental problems that are even worse
the person isn't son cost policy and
this is another econ I think this is my
last economics reference or don't worry
so the sunk cost fallacy is part of
human psyche when you've invested enough
time and energy into something you want
to defend that choice you don't want to
admit that you wasted those two months
becoming a Language X developer you put
in blood sweat and tears into learning
that language and you don't want to
admit that that was a mistake
we are biased to defend the choice that
we made we chose language X and no
matter how much new information comes to
our attention we will maybe not
intentionally but at least
subconsciously we will ignore that
information to defend the choice that we
made previously this is a real problem
and we see this happen a lot in industry
sure many of us can see times in the
past I can for sure
sure many of us can see times in the
past where we fall we've fallen for this
second problem is really the point of
the talk today that everything I've
talked about so far is at best half the
story benchmarks tell us about
performance as flawed as they may be and
that initial evaluation tells us about
initial productivity on a project what
I've not talked about at all is long
term maintainability of a piece of
software what's the bug count going to
be when maintaining software like this
how difficult is it going to be to
re-architect what if requirements change
what if the product owner comes forward
and says no no we've got to add a new
feature are you gonna be able to add
that are you gonna have to rewrite the
entire code base each time are you gonna
be able to bring your team up to speed
are you gonna be able to make a large
team productive on this kind of a
project inevitably there's going to be
technical debt are you going to be able
to pay it down all of these are
fundamental important questions to how
we write software and at no point in our
analysis
didn't we think about it once you may
think well hype is really going to
protect us here there's no way that all
of these people out in the world are
continuing to hype up the language and
talk about it and go on Twitter and read
it and say how wonderful it is if
they're going through maintenance
nightmares all the time that's not true
either I already told you that there's a
sunk cost fallacy and those same people
who are going on Twitter and reddit and
talking about how wonderful their
languages are subject to to the exact
same problem therefore we have an
information hiding problem this is a
functional programming conference so at
some point in here I should talk about
functional programming you would imagine
how is all of us related most
programmers today start off with either
imperative or object-oriented
programming those are the languages that
are taught in schools those are the
industry languages that are dominant in
industry today
these are languages they usually have
very large budgets for making very nice
tooling that's easy to get started with
because there's such a large market for
this there's a lot of educational
material either in the schools in the
marketplace and Industry O'Reilly
whatever it is B's the material is easy
to get access to and these languages
also have a lot more money for marketing
generating more of that hype as a result
of all of this we see that it's very
easy to on earth with these kinds of
languages and so our initial evaluation
is going to be biased against them I'm
going to claim we're fighting a losing
battle the way that everyone is doing
things today assuming that my assessment
of it was correct is not going to do a
fair analysis I'm gonna claim and
there's no evidence to back this up this
is just my own personal opinion I'm
gonna claim that when it comes to
writing the first version of a program
be won MVP whatever you want to call it
a highly trained Python developer and a
highly trained Haskell developer and
probably implement it in about the same
amount of time let's say 20 10 to 20
percent difference nothing significant
that may not be true but just go with me
on this let's assume that's the case
there's no doubt in my mind that if you
take a non-functional programming
experienced developer and you put them
down with Python and you put them down
with Haskell it will take them far
longer to do it with Haskell and I'm
saying that as someone who likes Haskell
they're not going to be able to be as
productive as quickly as they will be
with Python this initial evaluation
hamstrings us this is a battle that we
can't win on these terms now there's a
silver lining to all of what I'm saying
and I'll get into this a little bit more
later
recently functional programming does
have a significant uptake lots of
languages out there are talking about
functional programming people don't look
at you like you're crazy anymore
when you mention a fold so it's not
quite as dire situation and things are
better today but I want to make them
even better than they are so why does
all of this matter why why am I making
such a big deal about maintainability of
software in any kind of successful
project the initial development time is
a tiny fraction of the work that you're
going to end up doing especially once
you consider how many people end up
working on the maintenance phase of a
project if a project took six months
with a two or three person team to get
to MVP and then you have ten people
working from the next five to ten years
maintaining it the amount of time on
that initial phase is tiny we're
ignoring that long tail all of that work
that's going on at the end this applies
both to commercial and open source work
I've done I've written a lot of open
source libraries and I can tell you I
spend more time maintaining all of them
than I ever did writing them in the
first place we know for a fact that
requirements are going to change this is
just the nature of our industry we would
love it if the requirements document
came down from on high was handed to us
and never changed at any point in the
future it's not reality we know that we
are going to write bugs as painful as it
is to admit it there will be bugs in our
software and we are going to need to fix
it technical debt is going to accrue
architecture is going to need to change
to respond to things whether it's
changes in the way that in best
practices or changes in those
requirements and our standard evaluation
practices are not going to touch any
aspect of this at all
our industry needs to improve we write
buggy code the industry as a whole
writes buggy code unmaintainable code it
is not uncommon to do full rewrites when
it comes to v2 and that's not the way
that things should be so my goal my
encouragement to everyone really comes
down to this I want us to change the
conversation I want us to start talking
about maintainability more I want us to
be spending it to be putting it in blog
posts and getting it out there in social
media I want to talk about it with our
management next time management comes
forward and says what language should we
be writing this in the question should
be how difficult is it going to be to
maintain this if we write it in language
X versus language why sure we have to
talk about how long it's going to take
to get to to get to the first version in
production we need to include that talk
about maintainability also and don't
pass maintenance off to the junior devs
this happens all too often it's just
maintenance junior people can do that
it's insulting and it's wrong and
maintenance is not just a junior task
maintenance is hard work that even
senior developers can have a difficult
time with and claiming that the juniors
are just gonna take care of it is wrong
my belief and again this is one of those
places where I don't have any data to
back it up is that strongly typed
functional programming is great for
maintainability it's not a panacea will
not solve all ills in the world you can
very easily and I've done this myself
you can very easily write bad code in a
strongly typed functional programming
language you can design your API so
poorly you can suddenly break backwards
compatibility with semantic bugs that
show up in production or you can not use
the type system correctly and not
actually take full advantage of what
these languages are offering you but I
truly believe if you do things correctly
FP is awesome you're able to focus you
need to focus on quality and
maintainability to make that happen and
you still have to test your code do not
be one of those people who says well
compiled so it's going to work ship it
no tests are necessary also we don't get
a free pass what I'm talking about is
the things that we're able to add in
addition to what the rest of the world
has without typed
my anecdotal experience is that I've
been able to onboard co-workers to
massive Haskell code byte code bases
very quickly the fact that we have very
little mutable state we usually use data
type data types and we use data to drive
the way that the entire application
works we usually encode a lot of the
invariants and a lot of the concepts of
what's going on in a program in the data
types themselves it allows the compiler
to be your ally instead of your enemy
and then once you have that in place you
can do what we call compiler driven
development you change a line of code
you change a data type you hit compile
and four hours later after you've fixed
all of the places where it didn't
compile now you're able to run your
tests and if the tests us then probably
things went right I've been able to
refactor Andry architect code bases in
Haskell and seen other people do this as
well
in ways that I would have been terrified
to do in a lane in a different kind of a
language the fact that I don't have to
worry as much about mutable state
getting into weird situations due to
immutability the fact that the type to
do guide me through what I'm doing and
the fact that I get much faster feedback
from the type system than I ever could
from unit tests as well as much better
coverage of what I'm looking at now I
think you guys will Lynch me if I don't
include at least some code and then talk
like this so let's look at a few
examples
this is rust I'm choosing the rest
because rust is one of those languages
that has both an imperative and a
functional flavor to it and I want to
compare those two flavors both of these
functions do the same thing and of
course this isn't really a function it's
a sub procedure but they call it
function so I'll go along with it
both of these functions do the same
thing they add up the numbers from 0 to
9 the first one is an imperative
approach using mutable variables that
uses loops the second one is clearly
functional in nature it's using a fold
and I've had conversations about which
one of these is easier to work with and
here's how a typical conversation will
go the functional
probably most people in this room say
well the fold is obviously easier if I
go back and I look at it
fold looks pretty easy to most of us I'm
guessing but the conversation I've had
with imperative programmers at least in
the past and again this is changing his
functional programming is becoming more
common but at least in the past I hear
things like well you know that's that's
too complex
you have to like deal with closures and
all this other complexity its
higher-order functions that's weird and
I have to learn some new stuff I know
that loops always work so why would I
learn this new thing when I don't have
to and there's like this weird there's a
concern not a weird there's a concern in
the back of everyone's mind but the fold
is gonna be slower I have absolute
control with the loop and if you'll
notice this conversation and you think
back to what I said previously this
conversation talks entirely about short
short term productivity and performance
for someone who is not familiar with
functional programming idioms the fold
is going to take a lot longer to write
the for loop will be easier to write and
performance comes to the discussion but
obviously this discussion ever talks
about which one of these versions of the
code is going to be easier to maintain
and keep in mind everything that I'm
showing can fit on a single slide so
maintaining a piece of code like this is
kind of silly but just use your
imaginations and imagine scaling up to
something a little bit more complex so
let's say that we're gonna have one of
those weird changing your requirements
things that never happens in practice we
decided we want to only add up the even
numbers well this will work you'll
notice that in the imperative version
I've added in an if and I've checked
whether things are even before mutating
and in the functional version I just
added in a filter who here thinks that
it was easier to see the difference in
the functional version who here thinks
that being paired a version was clear
it's okay you're allowed to disagree on
this opportunity I happen to think that
once you get used to the idioms this one
is much easier to follow it's easier to
change the requirements let's come up
with a more contrived modification let
say that you want to add the number
three after you know that it's even so
you're gonna check if it's even then
you're gonna add three and then you're
gonna sum things up
which of these is easier to follow is it
easier to follow the functional version
of the comparative version functional
starting to get a lot easier to follow
by the way there's a bug in both
versions of the code which one can you
find faster functional all you have to
do is point out that map comes after
filter well the requirements clearly
said that the map has to come before
filter well that was easy
the imperative one you have to think
much more about what's going on you have
to think about the mutable state when is
I getting modified when is I being
tested personally I find that easier in
the functional version and again this is
subjective most of what I'm talking
about now is objective in my opinion the
functional one clearly allows you to see
bugs faster and therefore avoid the bugs
or fix the bugs much more quickly
alright let's talk about types I've got
a Python program and I've got a Haskell
program a Python program it defines a
person class a person constructor that
takes a name and then provides a method
to say hello to that person and that
possible program does basically the same
thing we don't have class well we do
have classes you're type classes but
here we're gonna use a datatype because
that's the equivalent we're gonna define
a person we're gonna define this
function greet and then we're gonna call
greet in the main function and if
someone who isn't familiar with Haskell
the Haskell code probably looks pretty
irritating what's going on with this i/o
thing why do I have to put types
everywhere what's with that unit doing
after the i/o why am I having to
deconstruct a data constructor what's
going on with all of this it's overkill
and an imperative or an object-oriented
program or probably it's not going to
like this too much this is going to see
much benefit in this especially people
who love dynamically type programming
languages but again let's say that the
requirements change and now we have to
capture someone's first and last name so
we update the data constructor I sorry
the the class constructor and we update
the greet function but we forget to
update the call too
constructor is this gonna fail a
compile-time and run-time well there's
no compile time of course run time it's
gonna fail the only way that you're
going to be able to stop this from
getting shipped to production is if you
have a unit test which is going to check
for this and you better make sure that
your test suite covers everything let's
see what happens in the Haskell version
in the hospital version I changed my
datatype and I changed my greet function
and now I have the exact same buck I
forgot to update the call and now the
person has a name instead of a first and
last name what's gonna happen
compile-time failure the compiler is not
your enemy the compiler is your friend
your compiler is preventing an entire
class of bugs from occurring at runtime
this is a good thing obviously a minimal
example like this isn't particularly
compelling if you can see all the code
at once and it's pretty easy to see that
there was a bug but you can imagine if
this was spread out over a hundred
thousand lines of code it's much easier
to let the compiler do the heavy lifting
for you than to have to go through all
of those places yourself just to make it
clear that I am making fun of other
languages let's make fun of Haskell a
little bit it is quite possible to write
dysfunctional Haskell there's a saying
in the Haskell community that Haskell is
the world's finest comparative
programming language this code is not
functional in any way we're using EM
bars which are mutexes and we're doing
multi-threaded transfers between these
two different EM bars I'm emulating bank
accounts which seems to be the only
thing I know how to do when giving an
example of concurrency in Haskell so we
create our first account we create our
second account these are both mutexes
and now we transfer between the two
accounts first in one thread going from
1 to 2 and then in the main thread from
2 to 1 and in the transfer function we
locked the mutex the first mutex and
then we lock the second mutex who can
guess what this program is going to do
this program is going to deadlock we've
locked we've locked the first variable
in the first thread the second variable
in the second thread and neither thread
is now able to continue and complete its
task if you write code in an imperative
style even in a language like Haskell
which is functional and purely function
and forces you to think in a functional
way even in Haskell you can shoot
yourself in the foot
so of course the solution is to use more
@p I think that STM software
transactional memory is one of the
coolest features that we have in Haskell
it's a great demonstration of what
functional programming and purity are
able to provide if anyone isn't familiar
with that STM and wants to talk with me
about it anytime today I will be more
than happy to talk your ears off about
why STM is so awesome so here instead of
a mutex variable and M bar I'm gonna
create a T bar a transactional variable
and our transfer function now looks
significantly simpler there's no locking
people who come from a different
background more familiar with STM are
probably thinking that there's a data
race condition here because you can be
modifying these things simultaneously in
two different threads however the way
that STM works is based entirely off of
functional programming sure functional
programming and the purity of Haskell
the referential transparency inside an
SDM transaction we know that there are
no side effects and the runtime system
is able to handle all of the retry logic
to make sure that we have an atomic
transaction that's why the word
atomically is sitting there on the
screen this program is not going to
deadlock this program is not gonna have
a race condition and we got all of that
by using functional principles again for
an example this small it's not terribly
compelling you could have made the M
bars work you could have done some kind
of ordering of the M bars and make sure
that you lock them in the correct order
but when you start getting into large
programs with large blocks and a lot of
variables the ability to simply compose
things together without thinking too
much is very valuable I'm also going to
throw in a little bit about my other
favorite library which is the async
library and this concurrently thing here
the fact that we treat IO as a first
class action as opposed
- something which implicitly just
happens allows us to write imperative
sorry a concurrent code in a very
elegant style and again if you want me
to tell you all about why I think basic
library is one of the coolest libraries
I will talk to you about that - I love
those two things okay so what can you do
what can we do I already said that we've
been getting the functional programming
ideas into the mainstream much more over
the past few years when I would go to a
conference 5 10 years ago and talked
about Haskell people looked at me like I
was crazy
people still look at me like I'm crazy
but then it has nothing to do with
Haskell at this point people aren't
afraid of bulbs anymore FP in fact is
usually seen as an advantage you'll see
lots of programming languages out there
touting the fact that they have
functional programming features
javascript is a functional programming
languages Java C++ they all have
functional features now that wouldn't
have happened 10 years ago so we're
winning that battle people are
acknowledging the fact that functional
programming offers something and as a
result of all of that the learning curve
is reduced when that developer that I
was talking about comes to compare
Python and Haskell they're probably
still going to find Python an easier on
ramping experience we're not nearly to
the same extent as they would ten years
ago we need to make it fun easy and
exciting to learn these functional
programming languages we have to
acknowledge the fact that people are
still going to be hitting that on-ramp
in cost and we need to give them
motivation to push through and continue
and I'll tell you the rest of my story
in a bit and you'll see how that ties in
and we need to change the conversation
we're fighting on the wrong grounds if
we continue to only talk about
productivity and performance we're not
going to be able to win we need to
change the conversation and get people
to think more about maintainability we
also need to be talking about practical
benefits
it's very nice Haskell functional
programming the lambda calculus these
are elegant beautiful solutions to
problems but if you talk to most
developers and definitely most managers
and you tell them about how elegant the
solution is they're gonna nod and
they're gonna continue writing Java we
need to make it practical tell them the
real bugs that are avoided the real
advantages the real productivity gains
STM that I just mentioned gives real
productivity gains
when you're writing concurrent code and
we need to be talking to that much more
what I wish is that we actually have
some data to back up all the claims I'm
making everything I'm making is just my
opinion and my my experience my
anecdotes we don't really have this kind
of hard data in our industry no one is
doing the studies to show that
functional programming either does or
does not help industry move forward
faster I would love to see these kinds
of studies happen I'm not particularly
hopeful that we're gonna see it doing
those kinds of studies would be very
expensive and there doesn't seem to be a
lot of interest in doing that so I work
it up be complete and when we talk to
companies about programming languages
about tools about anything
DevOps practices for that matter we
always talk about three different
pillars in software and its performance
productivity and maintainability and
you've heard me mentioned those all in
this talk performance has to do with the
hardware itself either how much Hardware
you have to throw out the problem or how
quickly the hardware is able you know
the same amount of hardware is able to
solve the problem productivity in
business terms is really easy to
translate
it's time to market how long is it gonna
take you to get this piece of software
out there maintainability is the bug
right evolving a codebase adding
features these are things that business
people understand they understand that
users are going to be upset when the
program crashes they're going to be
upset when they don't get the new
feature in a reasonable amount of time
because no one can figure out how to
modify the legacy code base these are
things that you can talk about with your
managers and get the conversation
started I'm talking about
maintainability today because it is the
most overlooked in my opinion of these
three all three of them are importance
we can't write software without
considering all three but let's get
maintainability back into the
conversation so I started off by telling
you guys how I got to be a Java
developer let's tell you guys how I
stopped being a Java developer I guess
it was 12 years ago 13 years ago I
decided to do some web development in
Java of course because I was a Java
developer it sucked maybe the situation
is better today I've been too afraid to
look
but at the time I just found it way too
painful it was so painful that I was
able to overcome by some cost fallacy I
was able to realize even though I've
been programming Java for years this is
not where I want to continue and so I
moved on to PHP which was a wonderful
programming language to follow up from
Java when I actually liked it because it
was so much more fun to write this code
than it was in Java after a year or two
of doing PHP I eventually realized I'm
not gonna be able to maintain this code
it struck me and I realized I'm just not
smart enough it's not something I'm
capable of doing I got lucky and I was
able to overcome that sunk cost fallacy
a second time
I then jumped around through a bunch of
programming languages the two that I
stuck with the most rapport were
probably purling D and I got two Perl
and someone came out with this thing in
Perl 6 called pugs it was the first
implementations anyone here ever heard
of pugs pugs was written in Haskell
which is a language I'd never heard of
before and I was curious what why would
they write this thing in Haskell as
opposed to writing it in pearl pearls
the greatest language ever created so I
looked into it I was a I was a math
person I enjoyed math I actually studied
math and school on computers and Haskell
was a mathematical programming language
so I thought hey why not let's have some
fun I didn't like do it for anything
real it was gonna be a hobby as I
started looking into it at the time
things are better now but at the time
documentation sucked it was all over the
place the tools were terrible this is
before we basically had any kind of
command-line tools you had to manually
run your setup that HS files and you had
to download tar balls directly it was it
was a mess
compared to what else was out there at
the time asked what looked like a joke
and I knew there was no way I was ever
going to use Haskell in production or
use it as part of my career it just
wasn't a reality but it was fun and so I
played with it I overcame that learning
curve and I stuck with it because I
thought I was going to enjoy the
experience and I did and I stuck with it
long enough and I was a stubborn enough
person that I fell in love with the
language and ten years later I'm still
using it as my primary programming
language
and through a lot of luck and perhaps
some self-delusion I found what I
believe to be a really great programming
language and even though I didn't have
the language ten years ago to talk about
maintainability the way I can today I
ended up finding the language that
addressed the concerns that I knew that
I had about writing code in a non
functional Pro approach we can't rely on
luck I got lucky
others may not it's too easy to give up
when things get difficult and just try
something else which looks easier which
is a completely rational thing to do
it's far too easy to make an initial
guess that takes you in the wrong
direction I did that multiple times and
many other people are doing the same
thing and then it's way too easy to get
locked into a bad choice I believe we
have a responsibility to help our
industry improve to get this one to get
functional programming out there I think
we can make the world the software world
and the world in general a better place
through it I am gonna encourage everyone
here to go listen to the rest of the
talks here learn much more about
functional programming and then take the
ideas back out into the rest of the
world talk about the benefits of
functional programming talk about how it
helps us make better code more
maintainable code talk about the
performance productivity as well we
don't forget to bring maintainability
into the conversation enjoy the
conference and learn a lot time for
questions yeah languages what are some
adapting languages yeah that we should
be learning ok no I mean I'll give you
my own personal biases my personal bias
is towards strongly typed languages so I
put I know so I personally prefer things
that give you a strong type system in
static type system functional
programming overall I think is an
improvement but I I personally believe
that getting the strong typing it gives
you much more of the benefit than other
things so you can extrapolate from there
which
which is I'd like more than others hi my
tea what was your first production
Haskell project and what was the state
of Haskell at that time okay so before I
moved before I left the United States I
was working as an actuary I was working
in the insurance industry and we needed
to do some kind of large data conversion
now this was large by our standards we
had to do up we were required to do all
of our programming and Visual Basic and
Excel so large there meant one gigabyte
which is obviously not a big deal but we
did a little bit of an analysis and the
way that Visual Basic was working
whatever it's one of my co-workers
discovered I was gonna take three weeks
to run the program
yeah so we decided well that sucks we're
not gonna do that so I did it in Haskell
instead that was the first and I think
maybe the only time where I got really
bitten by a space leak and I had to
debug one of those it was one of those
programs I was only gonna be run once
and then I was gonna disappear so no one
cared that it was written in Haskell I
got away with it and actually got very
scared when that's basically Catholic oh
my god I'm never gonna be able to solve
them solved it pretty easily everything
moved on from there yeah and that was it
and then we converted it and I think it
ran in like five seconds instead of
three weeks all right so first of all I
love this topic and I'm glad you decided
to do something like this the good news
is that I think your your cynicism about
the lack of research out there is is
unnecessary because I think actually
there are some people who have published
a few papers on strong typing and the
effects on bug counts and bug rates and
other productivity metrics out there and
so that they're happy people who are
doing some research like that but one of
the biggest difficulties is not money
for the for this stuff it's the fact
that nobody actually cares and this is a
and this is a real problem so I think
actually talks like this are important
because people don't want to invest in
the HCI of programming language design
and if you look at the big conference
where people are trying to publish
research on programming language design
it's almost impossible to get a
usability study published in those in
those conferences and so as a community
I think we need to be pushing strongly
culturally towards honest actual real
usability evaluations which we do have
the skills tool to do those studies it's
just that nobody wants to do that I
think partly because a lot of people are
very scared about the results of that
kind of research right so firstly if you
can share some of that with me later I
would love to see it
and yeah I mean there is the reality I'm
making all these claims but I think
functional program I think Haskell's
gonna rule the world it's the best
language we have to accept the fact that
we might be wrong the studies come out
and they say that everything we're doing
is incorrect I mean we could just say
the study was done badly but then we're
like the nutrition industry and we you
know are doing horrible things yeah
you're saying I'd love to see some of
that
this is regarding performance so as it
is immutable let's say I have a kept in
memory I actually think it's easier in
functional programming than an
imperative programming in order to do it
an imperative programming you have to
shove everything into the same loop you
have to make sure that everything and
you don't get any kind of composition in
functional programming let's just take
the lazy list example which is the way
that we do things in Haskell though it
applies elsewhere also in Haskell the
way that you would do these things is
you would just go ahead and change a map
a filter fold all of them together and
because it's lazy lazily generated it
only it always takes up constant memory
so it's going to generate one value in
the list it's going to put it through
that processing pipeline it's gonna fold
it together and you get constant memory
usage not in all cases you can screw it
up but for the most part you get
constant memory usage in these cases
there are even more advanced techniques
like stream fusion the vector package is
very popular in Haskell and it has a
stream fusion framework and with the
stream fusion it even takes it another
step and is able to completely bypass a
whole bunch of heap allocations and do
and if you look at the assembly that it
generates it turns into the exact same
thing that you would have written by
hand and C doesn't always work but in
many common cases that you would end up
having you get high level expressivity
and the low-level performance that you
want and I'd be happy to show you some
examples that there are some great
papers on it
the immediate answers yes it's a problem
we have to we have to solve it let me
elaborate a little bit it's not a
functional programming problem you know
the C language forms are infamous for
having this kind of attitude as well so
there is an elitist attitude in some
places I'm not saying my point is it's
not limited to functional programming
it's all over the place and anywhere we
see it in the programming world I'd like
to get rid of it I do think we need to
take some active steps towards
addressing it as much as we can just two
days ago I actually wrote a published a
blog post called new user empathy and it
was based yeah and yeah I know I
absolutely it was it was not completely
unintentional that I published it before
coming here I had all these thoughts and
minds as I was preparing this talk yeah
I absolutely believe that's the kind of
thing that we need to do a better job
with as a community figure out ways to
improve the tone that we use when we're
welcoming new people in and I don't I
don't have a complete answer and how
we're going to do it yeah I want to
solve the problem oh and the run
introspecting at the run do like getting
runtime statistics and things like that
right so we don't have tools that may be
as good as the JVM this is one you know
some some things out there are better
still we have some really nice profiling
tools built into the high school into
GHC and you're able to get great like
heat profiles and things like that right
out of the box we have statistics
garbage collection statistics at the
workshop that I did two days ago we
actually use the statistics quite a bit
to be able to analyze a memory usage and
figure out ways to improve things I'm
not going to claim that the tooling is
as good as other languages we definitely
have room to improve
hopefully you know this is one of those
chicken-and-egg problems hopefully
industry
come so massive around hassles you know
everyone's using Haskell tomorrow
Google adopts at the drop go they're
using it and then they you know they put
a team of ten people working full-time
on putting to making Haskell performance
analysis tools
[Applause]